[Music]
i don't say this to brag but we've been
shopping for our parents they're a
little bit older and uh we've been
wanting them to stay home
the last couple of months we've been
going to the grocery store and getting
them food and stuff and i came back from
one such run i live about five minutes
away from them and my mother said justin
you know i'm appreciative of you guys
shopping for me but
do you not know the difference between
curly parsley and italian parsley
because i guess i had gotten the wrong
kind of parsley she wanted italian
parsley yeah and i was so frustrated at
that point i've been having like kind of
a frustrating day anyway and going to
the store was just added to that
and so i didn't have much patience you
didn't want to get partially shamed
no you know the key part of that story
though is when you said i live five
minutes away from here i know
that's your fault well let's talk about
it all right here we go
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my brother
christian zachary who hasn't fully left
the nest yet either we move to a nest
very close to the nest yes christian's
right the key part is i'm five minutes
away i i got this house recently so i
can be closer to them to for an occasion
like this for such a pandemic the
decision to move close to them was more
general like they're getting older and
they'll need help but who would have
foreseen that they would have needed
this kind of help so soon it happened
like yeah a couple months yeah and
pretty regular help and
again like
we can't get too far into it because
there's way too much to unpack with you
know it's their parents uh i gotta save
it for therapy but um when she shamed me
about the parsley oh and i also wanna
read this text i got because it reminded
me of the sex that i got this is a
couple weeks ago she said are you coming
home today i was up at a place in
massachusetts i said no tomorrow why she
said are you
are you growing parsley at your house
outside where i could steal whenever i'm
up at the lake i try to keep my phone
away i don't want to be around it as
much so i just hadn't gotten to it this
was 6 35 she texted me that are you
going are you growing parsley i am right
pm
yeah oh yeah i should have cleared that
so it's not fully insane right now yeah
demanding parsley at 6 30 in the morning
yeah so this is like 6 40. i got that at
8 16 i got in all caps
and several exclamation marks and
question marks parsley
from her
and then christian wrote he has parsley
and she goes where exactly and i said
just to the left why are we talking
about this strange
family this new arrangement that i'm
living in i'm living it too that this is
sort of a modern kind of family though
you know because back in the day
i think the big advancement was the
railroad right that was the big
advancement that sent families away yeah
that sort of caused families to
relocate and uh move away yeah because
back in the day a couple generations ago
it was unheard of to move away from your
family you're sort of all stuck in the
same area right this wouldn't be this is
in a way what we're living is more
old-fashioned we're regressing to an
earlier time
yeah but it's modern in a way it is
still because it is a modern era and
it's a different way now to live and um
even our own grandparents like one set
moved to florida the other state in
rochester which is too far away to like
really visit that frequently
um but we haven't done that why are we
talking about our modern family well i'm
glad you asked
drum roll please our guest today
is on a show or was on a show called
modern family she didn't get fired the
show ended oh is that what it made it
sound like that's how i felt that's how
i interpreted it oh i think people know
that okay
um
anyway our guest today sorry to
interrupt your introduction well it was
going so well i know it really was god
also i feel like i
it's
it's i don't want to reduce her to like
she was just on modern family she's also
like an old friend and colleague and one
of my oldest people somebody i worked
with what is her name okay well
it's dame uh julie bowen our guest is
julie bone from a lot of dame but
should be if there's any justice in that
what is she lacking
what would prevent her from being yeah
why hasn't she been mated well maybe
she's too salty she's salty but i bet
judy dench is salty and has like a
sailor's tongue don't you think can you
see it be like just because everyone
probably thinks of her as oh damn judy
dench and this like you know she's
probably feeling yeah i bet she's got
like a bit i bet you meet her and be
like whoa
damn judy dan
yo did you hear what she just said dame
so julie bowen is uh a very important
person in your life because you did a
show called ed yes with her where she
played the female lead
it's my first show carol vessey yeah my
well people know this you don't have to
tell them i'm telling you no i know i
don't think people do know this because
it was we had a very loyal following
and if you're listening right now and
you did watch the show you're probably
somewhat incredulous like what do you
mean of course i know that but uh not
many people watched it um but yeah still
to this day the people who did watch it
seem to really love it and i love it
because it like you said it was my first
real professional tv and on that show
just for a little more context you
played an awkward high school student
and she was your teacher
uh not that unlike billy falau and mary
kay letourneau oh
you want to talk about that uh christian
i watched the married the mary kay
letourneau story last night which we
really recommend everyone do it's a
fascinating story we've always been
recently died which is very sad but it's
a fascinating story yeah um
anyway so you did not i was joking you
weren't a villain flower time you were
an awkward i was in high school teenager
i would have been a villain type had uh
on the show
acquiesce to my because you were in love
with her
and um i actually did make advances on
the show to her that character did you
know i professed my love and i i did it
through like shakespearean text and
stuff where like i joined a band and i
played to her and stuff like that it was
a really tough god i don't want to get
into it but it was just so fun to do and
julie was one of the
key elements that made it so fun i just
she's the i just love being around her
she everyone did um
so i i selfishly this was like such a
golden opportunity to see her again
catch up
and uh i hope you all enjoy it um here
it is let's just we just get into it why
not why not so here it is catch it up
with my old friend julie bowen
[Music]
i have three children playing with a
snake in the other room what could go
wrong
is that a euphemism no no although i
have forbidden pulling on each other's
penises in the bathtub i'm like a hard
pass i don't know where it goes i only
had sisters just like
you guys
i don't know why they pull on each
other's penises but they did when they
were littler and because they're 11 11
and 13 but like it's recently it's like
three years ago they would be like a
bathtub was a free-for-all i mean
i'm trying to remember how our parents
treated
penis because
well i remember my dad being in the tub
with us like i remember my dad's penis
when i was
little and thinking
it was so it was you it was like massive
there are so many ways in which i am not
going to touch this i am literally just
going to sit back and watch you dig out
of the penis hole right now well no i
just because my only frame of reference
for penises was with my own little
little boy wiener yeah i vaguely
remember my parents being like
addressing when i pull on it because
it's they're right there they're like
these it's hard not to
i i just i never saw i had sisters and i
never
had seen a penis until it was at a
tension and coming at me and then now i
have three little boys and i'm like
what the hell it's an
an entirely different equipment change
your parents didn't like i mean they
weren't like uh progressive they didn't
walk around naked in the house
now i mean my dad watched i said
occasionally but they were they my
parents are golf playing republicans
these are not the people oh yeah i love
them very much
and the lucha meyers
jack and susie lukemire am i making up
the von part vaughn yes you added you
had you made us vampires oh oh i thought
it was julie von luchtemeier no it's
just lucha camara
bowen
lutkelmeyer oh oh yeah bowen's your
actual middle name
i was listening i've been catching up on
all of your episodes and i was listening
to your jonah hill one and i was like
exact that's exactly right jonah hill
makes the choice when he's 18 and has to
live with it for the rest of his life
he's like feldstein hill well you know
these things will work out later and you
you have to live you live with this
choice you made when you were i was 20.
like that's crazy what kind of choice
was this
well what was your thought process julie
what what were you at the time was it
like luke demire's just harder to
pronounce well um
i think first of all justin i said i'm
sure you will recall i'm about a hundred
years older than you so it's so nice to
see you by the way i
made my kids we just watched galaxy
quest
the other night and then we went because
i was like i i've been listening to your
podcast i was like oh that's so nice and
i realized that my kids are exact
writings for galaxy quest yeah they were
blown away but when sigourney weaver
came on
one of them looks at me and goes
mom
why don't you tell us you're in this
movie
it was like oh yeah
you oh my god
i can see that she's got a wig and she's
got a square jaw
and
and i was like that is not me and
they're like yeah it's not sure mom and
i was like oh weird i know julie have
they seen happy gilmore
no
no the thirteen year old we have a huge
gummies uh poster in our house that's
painted on flower sex we're seeing these
movie posters in ghana they're these
movie clubs and they used to pass around
like vcr tapes of
bootlegged usually action movies like
lots of jean-claude van damme and to
advertise what they'd be playing at the
movie club that night which is literally
like a tv in the back of some store
they would paint on these huge flower
sacks the most
violent graphic scenes in the movie and
if there weren't any
they would make them oh my god so i have
a poster of happy gilmore where um
people are being killed and stabbed and
there's blood there's a
monster and a zombie
it's fantastic because that's very happy
no i was like
it's a i think it's a romantic golf
comedy it's like a rock oh my god
where did you find that my fake son
nolan um
nolan goulds found it for me gave it to
me for my birthday he was one of my
my kids on modern family so you have
this movie poster and your kids so
they're seeing it all the time and yet
you won't let them watch the fun on the
movie poster i am portrayed
um
roughly i mean
largely but it is they're like that's
not you i have like a beyonce body i
have like an itty-bitty waist and this
giant ass and like i'm holding the two
pictures of beer and they're like
they can't they don't really think that
that's me
um
but then i gotta see this yeah i know
it's pretty good you gotta send me a
picture
it's pretty good i will i have one too
i'll send it to you it's crazy where are
you now i see artwork
office at home my kids are in the other
room because it's summer vacation and no
one's allowed to go anywhere because of
coronavirus what is that let's see wait
there are two of them in the house now
what is it like three children in the
house oh yeah three twins that's right i
have twins and two 11 year olds and a 13
year old and they're all back in the 13
year old's room and i think of you all
the time because i had them all in one
room
forever in bunk beds and i remember
going to your house in connecticut yes
for easter and seeing the bunk beds and
they were i was like how did you ever
fit in here yeah they're little
they were like uh what's the smallest
twin i guess i just remember the bunk
beds
you have to tell me why it is that
christian isn't allowed to talk during
interviews he likes to hear it after the
fact and unpack the conversation
outro
i never listen to things in order i'm
terrible like that's very flattered that
you wanted him there though well i
thought there was so much that was
interesting between the two of you in
all those little intros and outros and
the things that you say to each other
and i was like there's a lot here he
keeps ending up on random vacations with
you like you crash a wedding and then
he's with you and i'm like what is this
relationship like tell me more well it's
interesting i've been thinking about it
a lot lately because now um i'm getting
to the point in my life where i think i
would like to have uh
some
how do i say this like you know romantic
intimacy
wait what are you
justin you have never been without a
girlfriend
uh oh i have for the last two years so
yeah what what what what is happening it
was just self-imposed oh are you an
intel no i'm no i think it's more um
i think the last relationship i was in
was uh i i i got into it too quickly and
too deep
i've just recognized certain patterns in
my
in my behavior that i wanted to change
and uh
and also you know it's harder now i
don't go out a lot i don't go to bars i
don't i haven't done a movie in a while
i don't
what's happening what's happening
well chris and i've been working
together and we directed this movie i
can't wait for you to see i've heard
about this because i've heard about it
on the podcast itself we promoted a lot
well you do i don't feel like you push
it i feel like you yeah actually then
again i don't listen in order
i i'm very i do this all the time i
during corona virus during quarantine i
listened to all of conan o'brien
completely out of order
completely out of order and i thought it
was fascinating because i would just
press a button and you could i could
start to tell where they were and their
run how their voices sounded and stuff
and i'm just just starting to get there
that way with you you have a little bob
a little blonde cut like you did back in
the day back in the day well i cut it
myself with some kitchen scissors
this is some this is the quarantine cut
you should see my kids wow alt-right
haircuts right now you know where like
it's like yeah
and then there's a long piece and that
by no means i'm trying to make any sort
of political statements they're all
blonde and they have like oh they i was
like we should maybe just not do this
for a while where do you get your
haircut
i get it over at a super nazi
they are bowen yeah hair bowen it's not
a great look for them especially since
i'm like airing on the side of
radicalizing them is how do you feel
about all this the black lives matter
and the and the looting what do they
think of all that the violence is kind
of the thing that everybody sort of says
well the violence isn't good i wish they
weren't breaking into stores and stuff
like what are they going to do with
supreme
shoes and i said
what would you do with supreme shoes
yeah and one of my kids said well
i have supreme shoes
and i was like imagine if you could
never have supreme shoes you can't work
you don't have it and so i kind of and i
was like sometimes smashing a window is
your the ultimate expression of outrage
against all the consumerism that is is
being pushed in your face someone said
you're radicalizing your children i said
i have to talk to people to talk to
somebody because i feel like publicly
you can't talk about it i feel like
right now you can't or else either you
look like you're like trying to be some
horribly obnoxious white savior
or you're oversimplifying i just try to
i know shut up and keep it at home well
i saw somebody posted something to
something on instagram that was like
don't be afraid to say something wrong
don't be afraid and i was like
that's not maybe the best message
because we live in this system now the
social media system that is just rife
with uh
misinformation and it's become uh it's
drawing these like tribal fault lines
sometimes
lines that shouldn't be drawn uh with
using information that is not factual so
i i thought that was a really strange
thing to say um and it's the and it's
the reason i agree with you i'm afraid
to say
too much because i also don't want to i
want to be critical of of what i'm
absorbing i want to take some time and
digest it i also don't want to upset any
group unless it's a group of [ __ ]
i'll upset races i stay off social media
in general but i hear people going you
can't be silent you have to say
something if you have a voice you have
to use it and i think
what is the responsible way to do that
because i am a white privileged woman
what am i supposed to say
that is not going to be
offensive or speak for somebody or take
their voice away and at the same time i
don't want to just like order gucci
online and and close the door you know
like i'm good the last person you want
to hear from is a celebrity i would
think you know what does the rock think
of this what does
uh bette midler think about this like i
that that's not the point but i think
the point of these protests is that
you're hearing from the people who do
matter when it comes to that
you're there you're hearing from the
people and that's that's really
encouraging where are you right now are
you in what country i'm i'm
i'm in ghana weirdly uh
uh i'm making i've tried to think of
that what was that movie you did with
tim out you did that move with tim ellen
joe somebody chose somebody yes i was
gonna make a joke somebody choked i did
not get tim ellen at his galaxy quest
you know pinnacle i loved him but he
would i think both of us after the
galaxy quest oh it was after yeah this
is awful but i was watching galaxy quest
and i said you know i i know that guy
we'd work together on ed my kids know
about ed they've never seen it and um oh
really they don't watch anything on them
they don't watch modern family they will
literally my older son has watched not
to watch modern family it's on not if
you're only thinking he watches youtube
or the office
and you know what their takeaway was
from uh
galaxy quest rayne wilson oh my god yeah
yeah they were like it's raining it's
dwight dwight dwight fruit's one of the
aliens oh my god
that's
that's what you see that's so funny your
mother's been on a tv show for 11 years
that's really funny what what are they
but they know that you went to work all
the time they knew that you were doing
that that's probably why they came with
me to work and they were there for the
final shooting day and
they were there a million times i've
heard other people say this who have
kids and have careers and stuff and and
kids just want you to be their parent
um yeah so that's all i've
i they yeah leah thompson said her kids
haven't seen back maybe they saw the
first back of the future but they
haven't seen the sequels
zoe or maybe joyce yeah has not seen
backstage they live
like a half mile i'm going to walk up to
the door i'm going to knock on it oh
really yeah
big fat vcr right under there
i'm so incredulous but wait they so they
so they know you did this thing i wonder
if that's partly why they don't want to
sit and watch it like they know that
this thing took some of your time
definitely did when they were little and
the show was a big deal and every time
we'd go anywhere they would someone was
blah blah blah blah blah blah modern
family blah blah blah and they would be
like
modern fellaini
and then as they got older um i think
that that's just a way to push back like
no when you're with me you're my mom and
that's what happens so if they would
come to set
and they and they
know just how boring it is
you know the day-to-day
no illusions of glamour of the whole
thing because god forbid any of them
become an actor
i love when i see uh oh god do you think
there's any chance
well my my oldest oliver is
funny as hell and he's so smart
and he's not great school he's not a
traditionally good student he's like the
most outside the box thinker i've ever
met like he has no idea there is a box
you you ask him what two plus two is and
he's like more interesting question is
what would you do if you made that
orange and you're like what
what like what
what does that mean he could be
a writer or an actor in tomorrow if he
wanted to be but but don't you think
don't you think you could have been what
were you that kind of kid were you more
studious i was super studious
you went to a really good school you
went to brown i went to brown and then
before that i went to boarding school st
george's
in rhode island yeah and that was um
yeah i was really i was super nerdy
and
studied really really hard and didn't
think secretly i wanted to be an actor
but i wasn't going to tell anybody that
did you act in school did you do plays
yeah i did plays in high school and then
in college i i was really intimidated by
all the brown people that i was like it
was
noah there no no no no i'm sorry no one
went to faster no
though because he was off doing a play
or a movie well that's why i thought of
josh because he did kicking and
screaming uh yeah yeah
well it's funny i think i remember
telling josh that
lily's gonna hate this that you had a
crush on him and you know such terrible
crush was awful is lilia's wife
oh lily's callie's sister yeah lily's
the best they're they're awesome no i
don't think
made this point i think she knows that
family thinks i'm just silly
yeah yeah no he was like oh yeah does
she uh i every time every time you had a
crush on somebody i'd be like i remember
thinking okay well why wouldn't they
just
marry you because i'm not easy
josh hamilton i couldn't speak around at
brown i didn't want them to like me
because i was like a girl or like i had
a question i want all those guys
especially aunts and the women too
that whole like ethan hawk crew robert
sean leonard
jonathan mark sherman they i wanted them
to respect me
oh interesting pete dinklage and like
yeah i want and i was like they don't
they have no reason to respect me so i
would wait tables and they had no idea i
was acting
at all i just told him i was a waitress
and that was that and then eventually
where'd you wait tables oh my lord
161 worcester which became casa la femme
open till 3 a.m i would roll her blade
home with like all my tips in my sock
and uh
i would coat check at another place on
18th street i don't remember the name of
where you had to climb a ladder to check
the coats because it's new york and
there's no room and i literally would
have to wear a if you wanted tips you'd
wear a short skirt and go up the ladder
yeah
yeah
why different days ladies why well let
me explain this to you
please do
so at that point you were focused on
being an actor totally i was taking
classes i was studying
i was um but i was trying to make money
in the meantime and i would save my days
for auditions and i do commercials or
whatever and if somebody noticed they
noticed they're like didn't you see you
on a commercial i'm like
um but i just kept going and i was i was
a reader
for hbo i just did everything i could to
like pay the rent i'm just hung up on
the fact that you were around josh
hamilton
and you are who you are and you didn't
feel secure to speak around it was josh
and ethan and pete dinklage who else was
in that crowd jonathan
forget it can i say that i made out with
sam i feel like everybody's made out
with sam i feel like that's not really
like i think leslie's gonna get mad at
that is she getting like hurt
like yeah i practically made it
it's just something that happens in a
phone booth in new york like you go in
you're looking around for a quarter and
you look up and there's sam rockwell and
you're like yeah should we make out in
this phone
yeah see people don't realize because
there are no phone booths anymore but
that was something sammy's
hanging around
phone was no i there was hey you need a
quarter there was some phone booth
that happened um
but yeah i think i set that up it yes
you did
i did yes
i forgot about that
that's what i'm talking about so this is
a perfect example and i didn't of when
you would say oh my god i have a crush
on that person and i would get like i
would get giddy at the anticipation of
being a matchmaker for
who i considered to be like the pinnacle
of
womanhood you were like the uh you were
like the platonic form of a woman so i'd
be like oh i eagerly tell hey sam
i got great news sammy that was sammy uh
and i did i i had a crush on sam but i
wanted like i never i always felt so
insecure around all those people
unless it was work oriented
and
i always they all did theater and i
always wanted to do theater i never
casted there i did tv and i didn't think
anybody any of those people would
respect that but julie now now you are a
big name why not that can't you now go
back and
say hey i'd like to do williamstown no i
don't know do you not have to the you
have is it like the 13 year old and two
eleven year old for a long time it was
for a very for a really long time i i i
got so lucky having this job that would
was was paying me well so and little
babies three little babies
and so i didn't work in the summer i
remember once you you came up to me at a
party
i was like how's it going how are the
kids there you go
don't have children
[Laughter]
i do and you said
and i won't mention who your girlfriend
was at the time but you said uh-huh i'm
not going to
not this is
that's not
this is not not this isn't the this
isn't the right situation um but but
it's funny
well i
i love kids and i've been hanging out it
sounds weird i've been hanging out with
kids my brother my buddy came up to this
uh
cabin on a lake and it's a really nice
place for kids to be it's i i got it
thinking that one day
i'd have kids and they'd be there and
grow up there but um
i don't know it just never
i just never
[Music]
it never worked out i never found
somebody that i thought but you're still
young how old did you just turn
i turned 42 i'm not that young that's
another problem is like in quarantine
how how do you do that i don't want to
you know i think the mistake i've made
in the past is getting to know somebody
over text or
over you know um over text and not
really being around them and i think in
the second year around somebody all the
natural pheromones and whatever chemical
you mean you don't like them when you
meet them in person uh no i just think
there's no way to really know until you
are around somebody's chemicals so you
have a reaction that's true i made that
mistake once because i i'm single now
and uh tried going on a date
did not go well because uh there was too
much texting and emailing ahead of time
and so by the time we got around to the
date it was a
crash and burn because i was just like i
don't know you i thought i i no i don't
know you at all i don't want to let
people down i have a hard time getting
out of things
um and so i stay in too long and then
before you know it you're 42. see this
is why i wanted christian here let's get
christian here and find out what's going
on like why are you not having a
girlfriend right now life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
have you thought about moving at la
moving back east i wanted to movies i
was uh i was married as you as you may
recall you were at my wedding late yeah
you watched yes
well really oh no
i did oh no well yeah anyway i was late
i was late you were late
it was a hurricane though you were late
you were late you by the way were not
the only one who was late
that was fun uh but they uh uh we all
sat together we should tell people that
we were on a show called ed i feel like
we were about me
yeah i met justin on a show called ed
which was about a bowling alley do this
in the intro ed was such a big part of
my life and i know that you're on this
iconic show
you said for 11 years which is nuts and
i know that's probably where most people
know you but it's weird for me to
imagine you being on any other show
yeah no i for me ed was still really
really really really formative i'm so
glad i did and i still have great
relationships from that i still see tom
and maureen and leslie and i and
jennifer goodwin are all moms at the
same school now that's right she told me
that yeah
right so leslie's last name is boone
yeah and she played molly hudson uh-huh
she married larry tang uh-huh
and she hyphenated her name boontang but
now she's just boone because she's
because they're they're divorced as well
that's right this [ __ ] happens how long
have you been a single lady i've been
single for two and a half years oh oh
hey same i moved uh two and a half years
ago so i'm not really sure when the
horse is weird like they don't send you
a diploma
i thought you got like a duplicate
movies
congratulations i know and you sit there
like with a with a pen and you're like
and you look at it longingly like yeah
and then there's a montage of all your
memories of like wedding and fun and
baby
and the singles here and then finally
you're like
and then you sign it and send it off
with a quill paper no i just i was like
one day i was hiding to my ex and we're
still really close we live really close
we talk all the time and i just like
said something about well maybe i said
does that happen after we get divorced
he's julie we've been divorced for
months i'm like what
i didn't even know weird
oh my god it doesn't
it's not a big they don't give you a big
moment like
wedding when you're getting married and
they're like i now pronounce you well
even any breakup i mean i've had my
share of breakups but there's usually
not a single thing it's not like and
that's it there should be the final
moment yeah like literally i had to do
this once in a breakup and it was like
here are the keys to the house i will be
gone for this weekend and you will come
and get your [ __ ] i had to learn that
the hard way because it otherwise it was
like a dribble drubble of like
drumsticks and uh
underwear or you know a special shampoo
or excuses to come over and make
mistakes and by the way i i'm on my side
as well i'm by you know me you know are
you close with any of your exes oh yeah
yeah yeah i'm close to my ex-husband and
then but i was married for 14 years
before that who was i dating david spade
sweet david
sweet david and i love him and i talked
to him a lot that's right yes and i will
say this to his face he's a lovely
person and a good friend not a great
boyfriend maybe not anymore
okay all right
all right
you want a date
he needs tea okay that's good advice for
me thank you you should not date david
spade
but i don't regret dating him because
he's a lovely person yeah he's funny
he's always been nice but i'm sure
people look at david spade i'm sure a
lot of guys look at him and they think
oh how lucky he
is with all these beautiful women and
one of my sisters like i don't get it
this is my sister molly and i took her
to his to david's stand up in miami that
year i mean so long ago and by the end
of the show she goes i'd [ __ ] him and i
was like you see
funny counts
yeah i guess so uh but that but then you
look at somebody's life like i don't
know i just wonder if that gets old i
mean
from david's perspective i don't know i
should have him on the show and ask him
no being with so many you know in so
many different
being single and
i don't know does it get old for you
justin
yeah it does
yeah
i i think now that i have three kids
there's i do have this feeling like i'm
always dating
i'm constantly dating and it's the worst
dates of my life i date three guys they
never pick up the check
they uh they don't make their beds
they're my sons these are my dates
[Laughter]
they i have to cook right right for them
and do their laundry but like they do
suck the
all of all of my time and i also i keep
thinking well i need to make more time
for like a social life for dating and
i'm like yeah where why where like how
like
i can't see where what i would give up
um right well maybe the times that i
know i know that must be i can't relate
i can't really
you have two
you've got two nieces or nephews now
right i have two nephews yeah i see them
a lot i mean i haven't seen them lately
unfortunately because of the quarantine
but
i love being around them i love being
around kids and then
i gotta say there's something really
nice about walking away oh no yeah yeah
so you know and i see what my friends
have gone through and i
i see how it's affected their lives and
and i i mean i can't understand how much
it's
enriched you're
for you for example how much your life
has been enriched by having kids but
i also know that it's a major change
if i was a guy i think i would still be
putting it off
really yeah
i think if i was like dude i would i
would still be putting up because you're
never ready
no one's ever ready to it's like you're
ready to grow a third leg you're like
what
that's gonna happen
also twins also twins that was yeah
and you're never ready but as a woman
you're heading towards this cliff of
fertility and it's like you better make
a choice you better make a choice you
better make a choice and whether you're
ready or not i knew i didn't not want to
have kids i did not know that i wanted
to have kids i was like oh interesting i
can't say definitively just like you
right now can you say i don't want to
have kids no absolutely not right
that's where i was but if you had a
cliff heading towards you that was like
you better make this choice by 35 36 or
yeah so i i went ahead and had kids and
i'm glad i did so when i was in new york
that was the last time i was just like
it's just me i'm making money
i'm not acquiring stuff i'm i just want
to see what i'm going to do with this
time and you know
oh i did nothing
i mean well that's not true well no but
i didn't i would go home and i'd be
bored and i'd be like okay this is new
york well you're a big reader you read a
lot yeah i would read i would walk all
over the city i would go to see weird
movies and all the cool little artists
what are you talking about that's like
what you should be doing in new york but
was i i didn't create anything i thought
if i leave if i really let myself get
bored i'll i'll like write the great
american novel and blood on a stone yeah
that's very carol vessel i did not i did
not i did none of the above i i do
recall not having a uh a tv
and getting a lot of heat for
i was interested it was a world series
going on
a mayor may not
have
slept with my neighbor to watch his tv
i mean it wasn't that transactional
it was not like that transaction right
that was just one of the components that
was an eight component he was really
cute and
he had a tv that was super i mean it
wasn't like like a garbage
homunculus wait it was it was disgusting
why didn't i just take
really cute guy that
if he didn't live you know what if he
didn't live in my building i would have
dated him
but he lived in my building so i
couldn't date him and this was my
compromise i like sports and i miss
sports right now yeah you were i liked
basketball yeah so that was one of the
things about you that i was like okay
one of the reasons that one of the
things that made you the perfect
woman perfect in my estimation you
didn't like sports in a way that was
like a passing oh what's going on with
the with the game where they're putting
the thing in the hoop uh you got really
into it you were like genuinely into it
yeah i love basketball i'm circling all
the way back to galaxy quest i thought
you had done that after
ed
and then i saw chill
who had a tragic accident and became
quadriplegic but he's walks in that
movie yeah chill was in a motorcycle
accident
i think he was on he told me once he was
on gravel
just him just like he just spun out i
think on like going not that fast or
anything but yeah chill so i talked to
bonnie zane this is not going to be
interesting to people but bonnie zane
cast galaxy que or cast ed ed and her
sister deborah zane debbie yes cast uh
galaxy quest i didn't know this she said
that they showed
the galaxy quest director and the
producers scenes from ed that we did
so that's how i got that job i didn't
realize that i didn't realize it was
such a direct correlation because we had
done the pilot remember that we did the
pilot that didn't get picked up
and then we had that and then a year
later yeah okay so it was in the
intervening time that's oh okay now yeah
yeah yeah and and during that time i did
this horror i did that movie jeepers
creepers and when that dad came back
around they said well i was so excited
for that movie to come out they said uh
you know they want to sign you to this
deal dad's gonna i was so excited to go
back to and do that show ed and but they
said oh they're gonna want a contract
for um i don't know five six years
whatever it is and i said oh i don't
want to sign that it's like this kid who
hadn't done anything
movies were flying at you i do i'd be
like yeah but they gave me an out i
remember they gave me one out which is
why i missed some of the fourth season
of ed because i went to do dodgeball i
did that that's right and you became
friends with vince yeah wait
you can't describe my face
no no
i'd like to your person is um an
interesting person very very talented
very smart
uh very funny
uh
and
um
is it fair to say
they're
vaguely divisive is that fair
yeah i don't like saying anything on the
show that i wouldn't say to somebody's
face so nor would i i would never say
anything
[Music]
uh yes he's a provocateur
that's the word that's exactly the word
he's a provocateur he likes getting
reactions and he gets yes yes
yes well he's i think he has a brilliant
mind and he
yes loves playing with people's
psychology you know he likes to affect
uh people
yeah that's fair you should do like a
radio show of all of just of you
imitating all the people you've worked
with because your vince vaughn is very
good
what is your i do not hear you do your
jonah hill i don't do jonah you don't do
jonah what about alec baldwin well yeah
alec is i mean it's very severe and uh
it's like piqua i was listening to
interview alec baldwin and i was so
anxious
and it was so clear that he adores you
and it was so well he's very impressive
yes he's a very impressive
conversationalist now what are you now
what now why did you say that why did
you ask me that
yes and now he it's like he's inside
your brain and he already knows
basically what you're going to say and
he has a great retort before you say it
any uh and you guys lived in the same
building is that how that was
an ex of mine lived
in his building okay because there was a
lot of talk about the this building and
i was like what a what what building is
this well well it was always annoying to
us whenever he i don't know if we talk
about this on the show but whenever he
would get into one of those
scuffles you know his run-in right with
the paparazzi yeah which by the way i
always
took his side on because
i'm sure you've seen the worst of those
people and how they get in your face oh
yeah he said he said on on on on your
podcast it's not the guy across the
street with the long lens it's the one
that is yelling stuff at you and getting
closer and closer and then especially if
you have kids that that is very scary
and and it's okay i've never had to yell
or or scream they change the laws out
here when my kids were little and i have
to like thank people that i never have
no relationship with reese witherspoon
and jennifer garner but push really hard
the pop rods can still take the picture
of you and the kid but if they sell that
picture
you can sue the paparazzi now it doesn't
stop them all the time
but it makes that picture a lot less
valuable but yes i've absolutely seen it
and they jump out of bushes and
do horrible things they chase you
through i remember i've gone through red
lights that have just turned red and
thinking oh [ __ ] that was close i hope
there wasn't you know but i want to get
away from this person who's and that's
totally fine someone i care about yeah
and then you'll look back and like oh my
god not only did that guy but there are
two guys behind you know no it's it's
not good and uh and the gotcha stuff
like i just had twins and they were like
nine months old and we were shooting
modern family in hawaii i was still
married my husband was there and i was
and i was on a
really tiny little quiet beach with
tybrell and his wife holly and scott my
my ex scott and i had just gone running
and i was really sweaty and i was about
to jump in the water because don't jump
in the water in your underwear and i was
like
so go back out i'm like no one's here
he's like just don't he's smarter than
me i want to try a room i throw on a
bathing suit but it's like a shabby
bikini it's like what i call a friends
and family like you should not be
wearing this in public it's like sex in
the wrong places it's lost as losses
and i had twins nine months before and
they do twins they mess up your stomach
good
and oh yeah on in clothes i was fine but
so we're jumping around oh it's cold
sitting down on the beach next to my my
husband and we're looking way far away
in a cave
it looks so far away but i can't get the
distance because the perspective because
there's water and then there's this
thing and there's huge balls and i was
like what did they do with those balls
in that cave and i realized
there were cameras they were
i still can't i couldn't get the
distance and i was like oh dear god
and just at that moment i was like oh no
well it's too late for me the friends of
family bikini and the and i had twins
nine months ago body has been revealed
but i look over and i see ty he's the
nicest guy alive and he's standing in
the water talking to his wife and scott
said you think we should say something
i'm like oh no just like they're fine
like they're not doing anything bad and
as i say that ty who is just a by his
own admission a country boy goes to do a
farmer blow like finger to the nose to
do like a big old like
like a loogie
sorry wasn't gonna say anything but had
to stop that moment
and showed him the cameras but
that was scary did you guys get to do a
lot of improv on that show because it
shot in a way that would lend itself to
that in the pilot we did
some
our director was jason weiner i've never
worked for him he's big on the improv
right he likes improv so if there was
room for it we would we would always get
as written
and then as time went on you start to
realize that i mean we did have some
phenomenal writers the idea of messing
like thinking that i was going to do
better than them
was not real but every now and again we
would you know we would pitch stuff and
pitch joking like what if and if it got
in if it made it into the cut uh ty and
i would like
this we never want to show exciting
world but we were so excited because
you'd think really long and hard and
before pitching you didn't want to pick
something's really stupid you wanted to
pitch something good yes and they were
always open to it it was it was just or
you know my own insecurity that kept me
back tai was better about pitching jokes
and he's also really freaking funny he's
quick he's really cool yeah but
i jump so those testimonials when they
shot the things where you guys were just
like
it was a documentary yeah that was all
scripted huh that's also a testament to
your acting it felt so organic we
wouldn't mess around with it some like
you know if we got it right you know
we'd be like can we try let's try this
let's try that and those were some of
the most fun i've ever had alone was the
being on that couch alone was like being
at your first audition for me bullets of
sweat dripping down
um panic dry mouth yeah yeah yeah but
with ty i was there i loved i i could
stay there all day oh yeah just a great
partner i hate being alone on camera
well really yeah i don't like it well
you're alone on camera right now yeah
but right now but i'm listening to you
i'm reacting to you like if this was a
black
thing that's true with the producers
would you just have to speak would the
producers prompt you they used to or the
director in early days they did there
was an x on the side of the camera you
know for eyeline in early days they
would ask sort of the question before
by the end
no we're just like
that's hard to do yeah that was but it
wasn't i mean it was still the greatest
job i i mean i have to go get another
job justin i have a feedback yeah what
do you want to do what what are you
itching to do next i was supposed to do
a pilot for
max muchnick and david cohan
um the will and grace people um but then
coronavirus happened so
i'm hoping we're gonna do that again i
mean it's not the worst thing in the
world to to take a minute but um i miss
it i okay now i'm remembering that
one was it i don't think it was the
pilot i feel like it was like one of the
first episodes
no it must have been the pilot because
you would literally i don't think you'd
been on
camera yeah i hadn't been and you kept
you were one of the funniest people i'd
ever worked with but you would like drop
out of frame you would do things like
like you would suddenly dart to the back
of the room or roll on the floor and
we're like this kid is hilarious wildly
talented just left the freaking
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
uh this is a weird pivot but have you
been back to italy since you were in
college have you studied italian
renaissance not no i've not been i've
been back to europe
but i haven't i was supposed to actually
go this summer it's just going to august
for a friend's birthday um and then last
year i was i also was going to go for a
wedding he had a lot of family drama
last year we had some we had some some
deaths so um
yeah sorry but it i mean it's it's all
fine i don't want to drag the party down
but it got
your parents no my parents
will never die and the healthiest
strongest like nothing will kill them
baltimore they come out here a lot we we
all share a house up in santa barbara
and so we all
that's where we all get together because
i have a sister i have my sister molly
who's in l.a and my sister annie
who's an employee
studies on coronavirus up at university
uh up at ucsf in san francisco
oh good he's gonna save us all
oh my god annie that's right i remember
them being both really impressive
annie's super impressive yeah molly and
i are both like who always think your
parents must be so proud of you and i'm
like my sister's an infectious disease
doctor like anything after that is like
we're just happy she pays her on rent
you know
we're just happy she doesn't she's not
you know in our basement doing drugs
the bar is pretty low now after that
yeah
what do they think of you being uh on
you know modern family and being a big
actress what did your parents think of
all that you said you were afraid to
tell i was afraid to do
to do the acting like you would you
would ask me like why did you change
your name and i thought well i'll give
this a shot for like five years
under the radar i'll use my middle name
no one will know there's no internet i
was the kind of person who wanted didn't
want to fail publicly i wanted to
quietly study and work and back then you
could fail quietly like you could do
yeah some tv that no one saw or play
there was a it wasn't things didn't live
forever on the internet so i thought all
right well let me i know there's going
to be some some failure in here and i'd
rather do it on my own time and do it
quietly and if it works out it it'll
work out like if it doesn't work out i
can always go back to being julie
ludkiner and uh i had an internship
at conde nast i think it was in the
interiors department at some one of
their magazines but ultimately what
would you have done with that like what
what you were an italian renaissance
studies
i was trying to where i worked at a
couple museums you do a lot of writing
the catalogues in incredibly in-depth
language talking about the twisting
circumference of the bronze
um
you know romulus and remus and like it
gets kind of heady because it's been
around for
however many hundreds of years and
you've got to find new ways to talk
about it
it's stuff that my dad fetishizes and
yeah i don't remember ever seeing
him be so struck by somebody as when you
started talking about you speak italian
yeah i remember at that dinner that we
had i do i remember you i always
remember your i mean i remember your mom
because she always came to work but they
were such lovely people but well he's
just he's a philosophy professor he but
he loves italy he loves italian
renaissance culture and so when he
learned that i think that was like a
bomb that was dropped on him he he was
it was flabbergasted wow don't tell him
that i have not gone back and then i'm
not very smart
he's very disappointed that you had a
successful acting career
well my parents thought it was i think
it was different back then than it is
now i mean now i have my kids and i'm
like
you're not gonna go to school for four
years and just [ __ ] off and drink
and like read good read the occasional
book like you're gonna go for a reason
my parents were like you can go for
whatever reason you want maybe go to
grad school or whatever because college
has always been expensive
but comparatively it was i mean it's
nothing like it is now
when my kids were born my business
manager said you need to make a million
dollars per kid after taxes oh my god if
you want them to go to private school
all the way through and i was like oh my
god
what that's what
i know and i was like that can't be that
that's that's not funny that's possible
wow wow well well la is crazy
yeah it is but you know i always hear
people i and i hear like you talked to
guests too on your show and like
i i there's a big premium on raising
your kids not in
la and not in the business and then i
think
but if if i was in um
uh
you know
i don't know tulsa or
austin or whatever
or even even smaller town like like even
in baltimore where i'm from
i would be the biggest name around
so all that attention would go to me
whereas here
it's very realistic like one we'll be at
the farmer's market and there's
paparazzi on my kids and then all of a
sudden they're somewhere else they go
why did they leave i go oh why because
gwen stefani just arrived and that's
that's real like it's
don't invest too heavily in any of these
same moments because they come and they
go and so it's more to me i kind of like
my kids seeing that i'm like i'm very
middle of the pack in in la i'm like i'm
a working actress but that's it yeah i
never considered that julie that is kind
of nice that your kids are living in
that environment uh and they're not
valuing that stuff are there celebrities
that they like are there people that
they're like oh i want to meet so-and-so
yeah but i mean like i can guarantee you
don't even know there because they're
youtubers they tend to like guys you're
like hey
so guys today we're going to fill the
entire pool with these balls that
explode over time and like literally
yeah yeah and i watch it with them i go
who's handing that up
mom it doesn't matter i'm like oh it
matters oh it matters
yeah yeah they light stuff on fire they
like set off rockets they just do like
cranky fun things they're not into like
um uh musicians all they like is rap so
i i don't feel like they're gonna be
hanging out with any of the lils anytime
soon
they just like rap
yeah lil gnaws little little nas lil
pump little uzi bear but it is
interesting to see those guys and my
kids reactions my kids not as much but
my i have some nephews a bunch of
nephews who were deeply upset by the
death of juice world
and i was like let's one day die
why did he died uh juice world died
because he ate all the drugs on the
plane
because the cops were coming
and i'm like teachable moment let's talk
about it
i was like so the cops are coming to
your private plane and you've got now i
might have the story wrong so please
don't write to justin and yell at him
but i do know that he was on a private
plane and someone had called the cops
because they saw lots of guns and drugs
on the plane he did like
a ray ray leota in um
oh in good photos with the helicopter
flushing eating flushing
like he ate all the drugs and then but i
was like you know this is sad a life is
lost but what have we learned what if we
learned about
getting on a plane with drugs and guns
and uh and are you afraid that oliver
are they getting to the age where like
they're being exposed to drugs oliver's
13 and he was on the bar mitzvah circuit
and
from i was not raised jewish
but i have so many friends over jewish
really
so i'm only only from their knowledge
like bar mitzvah circuit and that's
where you get your first [ __ ] that's
where you smoke
and i'm like it is
what it is because it is the first time
you drop off your kid who's wearing like
some version of a nice outfit at the
door of some like hotel or at a temple
and then they're going to take them
later to a party space that's like it's
like
it's like a prom but it's it's it's very
nice it's very expensive and it's not
unless you're close to the family the
parents aren't welcome until you're like
fine and then at 11 30 at night you're
picking up your 12 13 year old going how
was it like
good
what did you do
i found out later that oliver who was
hilariously funny you knew that song
comes on it's like shot shot shot check
yes
and of course they're not going to give
a kid alcohol i'm sure that there's kids
that drink these things they sneak it in
so they he gets a bottle of grenadine
cherry syrup that you use
and gets shot glasses and runs around
giving out shots of grenadine which is
just that's funny these kids all got so
sick from the just the straight shirt oh
yeah they got all hopped up on the sugar
yeah it was so but it's so much sugar
it's like it's it's so concentrated
wait why did they play
that song at a bonus but
what what's the name of that song by the
way
shot shot yeah
does it happen my favorite joke i have
no idea what it's called yeah it's just
called
cha cha cha
that'd be a funny karaoke song to do but
my poor kids have to put up with me in
the car because they'll be like mom put
on
uh
the box
uh
uh roddy whatever
ronnie rich whatever his name is
i don't know any of these references
so
it's it's actually had a really good
hook and you get into it and then it
goes into like well people say you can
have salty language on your podcast
right
yeah it's salty-ish um and they'll be
like they're like
and then it goes into like
i put my dick on the box and put my dick
on and i go
my kids my poor children
because my god
turn it off i go
pause let's talk about what we just
heard and they're like no mom no
i'm like what does it mean when when he
says he wants to put his
dick on the hot spongy wet place and
they're like oh my god mom and i'm like
no i just want it i just want to be
really clear
what if you're going to listen to it in
my presence we're going to got it you
got to know and they generally are like
just turn it off just turn it off it's
not worth it it's not worth it and like
their friends get in the car like what
do you guys want to listen to do not say
rap
well okay yeah
well at that age especially the the idea
of your parents i mean still to this day
the idea of my parents there was
somebody
sometimes people writing with would you
rather as christian i love would you
rather and somebody uh did one would you
rather your parents
watch you have sex
for however long or you watch your
parents have sex and i'd rather watch my
parents i'd rather watch my parents you
would
yes
oh i would rather poke my eyes out
before do any of those right that's not
an option if if like if they're holding
one of my children above like a pit of
fire and i have to choose
i'd rather watch them have sex because
then
it it might sear my eyeballs but it's
they have to be naked doing it like i
could not be naked and vulnerable like
that in front of my parents i i i know
i'd be if i mean for a guy i mean
physically it'd be i would imagine it'd
be impossible
to get too graphic but
right you would you would you'd have a
hard time
so to speak yeah yeah what did you pick
you picked you doing it
i'd pick me doing it yeah i'd have to i
couldn't
i couldn't see that i couldn't see it
and i it'd be very but again like my
concern is just the performance element
i don't think i could i don't know how i
could
[Music]
yeah
you probably have to go i'm sorry this
is taking so long it's so fun oh no it's
so fun seeing you i can't even tell you
you're you'll always have a very special
place in my heart
oh yeah likewise all right i have to you
have to give me your lightning round
because i have seven okay minutes okay
what is your most commonly used emoji
disappointingly my favorite emoji is
that i say the emoji instead i say i'll
say like smiley face emoji or thumbs
down emoji because i have so many
friends who won't use them or don't
approve of them or are old and don't get
it so i'll just say insert eye roll um
or whatever it is so i tend to say
like sad face emoji a lot that's funny i
just say all right
okay but with your kids your kids must
use emojis
oh that with my kids it's it's almost
always going to be a thumbs down yeah
thumbs down
okay because they'll send me a picture
of like mom can i get this pet rat and
it's just
yeah okay do you have any pets
a snake
oh little oh that's right they're all
a snake a ball
constricted python a ball python a ball
pipe yeah did you why do you know what
this is
is that at all impressive that i knew
that yes yeah how do you know yes
i was a big jock in high school
no i was a nerd i'm a nerd
most people know what a ball python is
no it's uh there's reticulated pythons
there's emerald green bow i mean i know
all of them
yeah yeah you know
a ball python named eden she came named
with the name eden get it
and then we gave her her rap name is oh
cover
for cardi b because we're big cars i
thought it was gonna be little eaten no
bowen
that's a pretty good cardi b or card
oh god we're old um okay if if you could
be a professional athlete what sport
would you basketball
yeah i could never play ever no no i'm
terrible but that's the game are you a
lakers what are you now a lakers fan
no clippers
and they're going to finish the season
and
yeah this was the one year that the
clippers could have actually really
wasn't the only season a few years ago
with chris paul and and uh yeah blake
griffin blake oh my god yeah
yeah
uh so much as i put my hand on my shirt
thinking about them yeah you're rubbing
yourself i am i'm rubbing myself a
little but in a very innocent way i love
basketball i love basketball players so
yes i'm a big clippers fan okay all
right uh if you get up one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be cheap
popcorn with the white cheddar cheese no
smart pop
when i was pregnant i used to stop smart
food i used to stop on my way to work or
on my way home from work because i
worked in manhattan beach
twice
to get more smart food and just like
cheetos like dusted
licking
pirates booty
i like it but it is not as greasy and um
and and it's too healthy ah okay
what's your favorite movie of all time
or or maybe top three if that's too much
my favorite thing on your podcast is
when people go that's a terrible
question justin
that's what alec baldwin did yeah that's
terrible um no i don't have a favorite
movie i have movies that are comforting
like right now
they're all period movies i love a
period for cover emma right now
i've watched four times
i just keep going
yeah i find it so
comforting to watch people from a
completely different era
having their situations whatever it is
like pretty much any
any jane austen movie merchant ivory he
is very escapist yes and i love it if
you had to live somewhere else where
would it be i mean i there's a fan
there's a place that that doesn't like
have a name because it only exists in
movies of like a small town in like
idaho where the kids can ride their
bikes and
you know everybody walks to school and
nobody locks their doors i don't even
think it exists but i'd love to live in
america but this version of america that
i don't know where it is where it's like
small town and really simple if the kids
want to do meth they've got to find a
car and drive really far
they have to go out of their way yeah
they're going to work hard for them yeah
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met who who would they be the central
person matthew michelangelo because i
was an italian renaissance studies major
and he was i mean we didn't have
evidence of this but
pretty sure he was gay
um he had this very uh long-term
relationship with a woman that was
platonic and so i've always wanted to
david is also so
i mean yes one need look no further yes
and he also he he was not comfortable
painting the female form
one of the few
classic artists is like
like kind of just stick some boobs on
like a bad plastic surgery thing just
like honk monk and you're like you're an
amazing you could do anything
what do you say you took david's body
and just put boobs on it basically
um but i would love to have him and then
i would love to have like some
super right wing
gay beating gay hating person and like
harvey fierstein
and i would just like i feel like i
would i just feel like poor michelangelo
probably had to live in a closet his
whole life and he just needs the poor
guy i just i hate like anita bryant you
know yeah yeah somebody's just like
really
not not positive i i would not want to
have a um
a quiet calm dinner i'd like a really
spicy dinner jesse helms and
yeah yeah so yeah that's a great dinner
i'd like yeah well i like i like a
controversial dinner and then i'd like
to see like
harvey fierstein just rip and need to
brian to shreds or jessie whoever it is
joking
i like a little chaos
who's your favorite muppet who's the one
that doesn't talk is it beaker banana
he was the first time when i was a kid
that i wanted so badly to hit rewind
like there wasn't it wasn't taped i was
like mom we have to watch that again
that was it that was everything
i love the way his mouth moved beakers
my favorite too uh
if you get one superpower what would it
be
time stoppage
um yeah just be able to pause
the world i could do like yeah
i could do like laundry dishes go work
out oh that's what you would do with it
no
yeah yeah i would do all the boring [ __ ]
so that then i could go back and have my
life and not have to do that stuff in it
because it is so time consuming to do
all the boring [ __ ]
so i would love to get all that all that
like
you know paperwork and all the stuff
done and then then be like play time
it'd be really fun
what's the first thing you would do with
your free time you have you have a for a
solid hour you have an hour to do
anything
oh
oh no
because i'm like i do get crippled by
free time i'm totally crippled i so
rarely have it that i get i get really
like
uh my friend said that he just had a
baby that yeah the baby is like maybe a
year a year or two years now and and his
wife is like you should do take an
afternoon for yourself like you've been
what are you doing with the baby and
i've been
and and he gets like uh oh i don't know
what to do he ends up just watching tv
and like yeah there's very few things
that i know how to to to do
um
and especially my house if i'm at home
forget it is there something that has to
be painted or fixed or whatever
distractions yeah
um if you have to be one age for the
rest of your life what would you pick
30 i think pre-kids but i wasn't like
because you can't you literally you
trade in one body and you get back
another one you're like you're gonna
have kids then they send you back this
so you know an amalgamation of parts
you're like what like crazy boobs they
go big and small and like everything
goes whack-a-doodle so i'd say yeah 30 i
could still run like i run now but not
as much you know injuries injuries start
to get to you and get older so 30. i
know i wouldn't want to break down 120
though that was
yeah you're still figuring out how your
body works um it's just horrifying
yeah it's just like an oozy it's like a
bag with fluids that is betraying you at
all times
just a porous bag like oh i'm sorry i
don't know what's happening would you
rather be called unattractive or unfunny
oh
oh i i'd rather be called on an
unattractive any day of the week yeah
yeah i if you could be guaranteed to be
one or the other i would take funny
which golden girl do you most identify
with dorothy blanche rose or sophia b
arthur b arthur a thousand percent
really oh
plus i've heard stories about her one of
our um the creators of modern family
chris lloyd was ran golden girls too
oh wow and he has
stories
that oh he must have gone right he does
and let me tell you bea arthur is a
salty and is uh
uh
fantastic is all i can say yeah as you
could ever want her to be you have a
snake but dogs are cats if you oh dog
dog
my ex has it has the family dog that
comes back and forth sometimes but the
snake lives here were you raised with
religion julie were you guys religious
um
cnn cne christmas and easter
you've never heard that
no no
see any episcopalian presbyterians yeah
what's your idea of an afterlife when
you think about like oh god i think this
ended uh do you ever think about your
own legacy or mortality or where i know
that's that's not a lightning round
question no i i don't think about it one
i went recently with a friend of mine
had lost his wife and we went a couple
years ago and they had an unveiling of
the headstone
and so we go back you go back you know
when they do that in the jewish religion
you go back a year or two later for the
unveiling
really you're put you're putting a
button on it but at the same time
you're also really nailing down this
spot where the body is i can imagine
like no offense to the people that like
that that's great i never want to be
anywhere where anybody can go visit me
burn me up spring around my family had
the first crematorium in the united
states no kidding yes in 1790 i think
six it's the lemoines which is my dad's
side they were french
doctors
in ohio
and it still exists you can go visit it
in washington ohio the lemoine
crematorium because they were just like
it's unhelpful to be fair to
they thought it was unhelpful to bury
bodies
and i'm it's not yeah i'm like i'm with
you i mean i'm sure they've figured it
out by now but for me
no i want to be gone
would you be cremated in that
crematorium oh my god no because it i
think it's literally like um
i mean it literally looks like a pizza
oven i just don't think
i feel like that would happen
no i don't think it's got the kind of
industrial strength heat
that now they just okay
okay that's what i want i just want to
be like
vaporized
i don't want anyone to stand around and
see like smoke rising or anything i just
because when you're to me
when you're gone you're gone i'd like my
kids to take something away
they don't like me all the time
and i just hope that to myself like
someday
and maybe that's what you mean maybe
that's a legacy someday they'll go like
last night we were folding laundry and
all i got all over you gotta do it again
that's bad because it's laundry and i
said someday you'll know how to fold
laundry and some girls can be like
who taught you that full like that it's
kind of fun you're right you're right
but if i were oliver that would annoy me
too oh wildly but like yeah i hope that
one day he's like you know my mom drove
me nuts but damn if i can fold or i can
cook or clean or whatever none of them
are below the potential that they could
be i mean they just they all kind of
function at a low hum and sometimes you
got to turn the fire off sure
yeah jump start them yeah right so and
and
they've all become slightly
slower and dumber um okay you gotta go
uh um okay got you i love you it's good
to talk to you i love you so much i'll
see you soon bye hopefully
[Music]
well
that happened
whoa why
it's a sigh of happy enchantment content
and nostalgia is a kind of melancholy
had you not seen her in a while it had
been a long time trying to remember how
long i think the last time i saw her was
in the early 2010s we were at
an award show and uh i especially loved
running into her at a place like that
because
i just feel so close to her that when
you run into somebody in such a
an uncomfortable like hollywood social
setting they feel like a life raft you
know there's this understanding that we
know each other on a level that goes way
beyond the superficial
[ __ ] and it's so comforting it's
really like great um but
it had been a long time and
she's gone through a lot of changes i
haven't gone through many you move
closer to your parents that's true
that's a big change you learn the
difference between italian parsley and
curly parsley that's true by the way
if you're still listening after having
heard that little teaser about the
parsley
my mother was right it was actually a
good lesson she said and she's such a
good cook she said that italian parsley
is much more flavorful i already knew
that you did i never buy curly parsley
oh why didn't you tell me i don't know i
could have avoided all of this
uh yesterday it's also easier to manage
the italian parsley when it's not so
curly you know oh see for some reason i
always i like the idea that the because
i use it in smoothies a lot in morning
smoothies see another change
uh another yeah but now i'm gonna start
and i saw it grow curly parsley i'm
gonna start growing italian parsley
anyway uh this just reminded me of when
i was talking to julie about feeling old
and her kids are into this like rap
music that i she was referencing these
things that i
it's just made me feel even older than i
am yeah i i had her little uzi vert
though i'm trying to remember why i
remember clearly when she came to our
house for easter oh yeah our parents
reaction to it was
just something unforgettable to me
they were like
a gape yeah it was like uh i've rarely
seen adult human beings a gate it was
like at another human being
they're like you know that scene in
jurassic park when sam neil and laura
dern are like they're in that little
jeep and they're like what what is it
and richard emerald's like look over
there and and it's it's the reveal of
the brontosaurus for the first time
where you
see and there's that pushing on samuel
where he's like oh my god i guess it was
close to that yeah yeah that's that's a
good announcement
it's just like and pause samuel and he
like taps mom laura dern and it's like
look look and she's like what is it
jimmy oh my god yeah they like couldn't
wrap their head around what they were
witnessing well because our mother
i hate to say this but she can be a
little superficial about she can be more
than a little superficial okay
and she appreciates uh pretty lady so
there was that it was just like oh my
god the julie looked like everything you
know
so beautiful and
and then pass she opens her mouth and
she's like witty and
charming and and knows about italian
renaissance
and can speak italian oh god they were
like floored
they were i downplayed it when i was
talking to her where does someone like
that develop that salty tongue i don't
know i i just really loved it and i
everyone at work did she was so beloved
on on set um it was a great show i
learned a lot watching her and tom
kavanagh who played ed uh who hopefully
is going to be a guest on the show i am
a little surprised that she so quickly
identified as a dorothy that's what she
thinks i see her more as a blanche i
think so and me and a little um i would
say a little uh
sofia salty and like yeah i guess she
comes into a room and but blanche is
more of a good time charlie she's a good
technical i mean julie's a good time and
but like with a proper backdrop you know
she had this yes proper upper oh you're
right boarding school yeah
i guess what i'm hung up on is the
saltiness the sassiness and uh not to
put words in julie's mouth but i think
because she then followed that up with
something about bea arthur and how
somebody on her who is like a producer
on her show
knew b arthur would tell these great
stories and i've heard this about bea
arthur is that she was like groucho marx
she was like memorably really quick and
salty and um
maybe she was conflating bea arthur with
dorothy well they don't come any quicker
or saltier than julie bowen then maybe
she was she's a b arthur and not
necessarily as much of a dorothy huh
that's that's a good man
mansplain point thanks for explaining
that to me sure thanks for mancepting it
god i wish i could interview
a cast of the girl how great would that
be to talk to the golden girls well
you know that there's a golden girl that
we could talk to there's only one yeah
let's read a letter okay
oh uh this letter it comes with a really
cute picture of a girl probably about
five holding a frog so i'm excited
uh it combines a lot of your favorite
things
it does
cute kid yeah frog ah that's it there's
woods in the back it's all you need
um that sounded creepy to add the woods
part
uh the kid in the middle of nowhere okay
no adults get in the way
that's all right
this is from hey christian another one
my favorite really yeah christian t
subject so would you rather is from my
yes from my eight-year-old daughter
freya and me eight you said five sorry
freya no it's a good thing oh yeah she's
not for a kid when you're a kid you
wanna look older i don't think an
eight-year-old cares that's true that's
true
uh hello justin christian and maggie oh
a first letter addressed to maggie as
well
although i live in your neck of the
world oh hey fairfield oh cool i'm
english oh
so please feel free if you read this out
loud to do so in a weird cockney
australian accent well touche
touche christian
i want to say a quick thanks for your
podcast and i hope your grandmothers are
in fine fettle ah you can't read that in
an american accent fine
fettle what a great expression listen to
your podcasts as i pretend to conquer
tools around the garden has been a
reassuring constant in a world spinning
into collective madness yes this guy's a
great writer
the gerry o'connell and david harbor
episodes in particular were great
my eight-year-old daughter freya also
likes to listen that's awesome which is
and he's in fairfield yeah somebody
could be friends with this guy no no why
are we hanging out now
which has expanded both her general
knowledge and library of curse words out
boy sorry chris apologies
the would you rather section in
particular piqued her interest
she also has a pond and two frogs called
hippie and hoppy how do you think i feel
you're glowing yeah
she has two frogs it's a little man-made
pond you can kind of see it in this
photo that's cool a little vernal pond
no now we've talked about this yes
virtual pond is not man-made no think of
the etymology of the word vernal vern
vernal spring green yeah
uh every spring
this pond when the ice melts well and
thaws the rains come the rains come yes
but also thawing process
uh it creates a little dip in the earth
wow resulting in a little earth made
pond yeah what's the key though to a
vernal pond what's the key difference
between a vernal pond and a regular pond
it happens in the spring and it's
not long lasting right
okay oh god
sorry listen sorry everybody but maybe
freya learned something
she also has a pond in two products
called hippie and hoppy that makes me
happy my would you rather is
would you rather a pippi and hoppy makes
you happy
would you rather is would you rather
have to take an upstate new york road
trip once a year
once a year every year with donald trump
wait wait wait wait wait wait upstate
new york road trip once again it's not
bad once a year it could be in the
summer i i would say new york in the
summer but here's the beautiful here's
the condition i didn't i didn't read
that fast enough but you'd rather have
to take an upstate new york road trip
once a year every year with donald trump
where you go antiquing have an afternoon
tea where you have to wipe crumbs from
his mouth then share a room and have to
talc him like a big baby
and gently brush his hair while you sing
him a lullaby until he drifts off to
sleep or
talc him okay how can like a big baby
talk
powder oh
or punctuate the end of everything you
say with the words totes
while using air quotes every day for an
entire year
that this is a complicated one okay
so everything you say uh everything you
say you have to say totes totes
that would just get so complicated i'd
rather do the donald trump thing much
rather i would too yes for a few reasons
one i love upstate new york
i don't love antiquing but it's but this
all sounds nice between the two options
the first one leads to a much much more
interesting experience yeah also i mean
say what you will about donald trump
it'd still be interesting fascinating
yeah i would i in fact
i would want to do that i think i don't
know if i'd want the commitment of
having you once a year well here comes
your donald trump it might be it might
be really fun fascinating to learn to
hear from him and to meet him also
christian not to mansplain to you what
uh your
what your would you rather entails but i
would imagine that he's amenable to all
this he's agreeable
of course because i have to imagine that
yeah because otherwise the secret
service would take you down oh yeah and
if you were to talk him like a big baby
he'd be kicking and screaming he'd be
pushing you away oh if he wasn't
amenable to it i would definitely pick
the other one he'd be impossible but if
he liked me i wouldn't be able to do
that if he would if he liked me and i
could pick his brain and we get a nice
limo ride through upstate new york also
talk about being able why wouldn't i
want to do that being able to dish with
your friends like julie about your
experience great [ __ ]
baby donald trump could be not baby
donald trump adult donald trump it would
be a great story it would be so fun to
tell people christian says you have to
it's an afternoon tea where you have to
wipe crumbs from his mouth that's not
that bad happens
yeah then share a room share a room not
share a bed
well maybe that's implied share a room
it's very british it's a very he's
really tiptoeing around this in a very
british uh classy way if someone said we
can curate this experience oh yeah i'm
sorry he says
he drifts off to sleep sorry oh so if
someone can says to me uh we've curated
this experience for you with donald
trump this antiquing trip upstate new
york
uh here are some of the conditions you
have to talk him you have to wipe crumbs
off his mouth
would you want to do this yes or no i
would say yes i would too you know both
have to want to talk and wipe crumbs off
donald trump's face from you i want to
hear you [ __ ] um
yeah i would too also like i love
communicating with you i think that's
that would be a that you would have
missed opportunity but also the flip
side is
to communicate with the words totes
while using air quotes every day for an
entire everything you say it could be
annoying oh it'd be annoying for
everybody annoying for me no one would
want to be around your life wouldn't
improve at all or you would you would
gain no insight into anything it would
just be a nuisance it'd be a lost year
yeah easy christian is easy okay
oh great i'll he's in this back to
christian he says i'll hand it over to
freyja from here
number one
would you rather kiss a hairless rat or
eat worms alive great questions a
hairless rat or do what
eat worms alive uh this is a hairless
wrap me too what's the second one would
you rather have a tadpole up
would you rather have a tadpole up your
butt for a week
a week straight yeah i've imagined a
living town what's the difference you
choose like well sometimes you need to
take it out for important reasons
obviously be dead you know
would you rather have a tad pull up your
butt for a week or a beetle in your shoe
for a month biting you and making pus
come out get out of here the butt
yeah i'd rather as long as it didn't
prevent me from performing certain
natural functions yeah now
this would have plugged me up for a week
would you not be able to make doodoo
i'm speaking in phrase oh right i wonder
what uh british young british kid would
call
that uh would you rather
oh you know i this is kind of a gross
one but i heard
somebody said um when they were a kid
they would say make
i i have to make who was that do you
know who that is i thought that sounds
familiar and and maggie uh christian
addressed this letter to maggie maggie's
when she was growing up would say uh her
mom had say bundle yeah so now she hates
the word the other day i and maggie's
very you know she's she's not squeamish
about many things the other day i was
like oh i have to
there's a bundle i have to bundle these
papers together i use the word bundle
and she was like oh
and i was like what what papers what are
you
objecting to and she goes
that word a little
bundle
and she was like don't say it and she
explained to me why yeah that her mom a
poo it was she
had what they called poo
bundle dollar yeah
and then i thought like well i've been
around her for how long now and i've
never i just i just never used that word
bundle yeah freya i would rather have
the tad pull up my butt
as long as it didn't prevent bundles
from coming out
which would you rather have a bug in
your is back to freya's letter number
three would you rather have a bug in ui
for a month or have five ticks
or i have five ticks and then she says
to clarify and to personalize it she
said i had a bug in my eye for almost
the full day oh fria you did freya
wow wait it's five ticks where uh she
doesn't clarify five ticks like in an
aquarium
in a little tick community
uh
no
in a tic-tac container that's where i
would but to carry them ticks are awful
and you know we also live in connecticut
where um you know the home of old lime
connecticut which is birth places i
think it's just lime yeah it is there's
lime and old lime right sorry it's just
from lime there's new lime um
so so the question is would you rather
have a bug in your eye for and the bug
is not a tick or have five ticks uh
if the five ticks haven't bitten me
oh this is a tough one actually freya um
i would probably have i've had ticks on
me and if you get the tick off right
away you don't run the risk of i don't
think you get lyme disease so i would
rather have five ticks assuming that the
ticks didn't lead to anything like lyme
disease
and the thing in your eye didn't lead to
anything other than the annoyance of
having something in your eye
i would pick the ticks yeah because
obviously lyme disease is a horrible
thing yes um
but the ticks themselves when they bite
you i don't think the nuisance factor
the pain is significant enough to
even have it disrupt your day right no
i've been bit sever i mean just this
summer not to brag but i've had a couple
ticks on me whoa
um because a bug for a month i mean
freya you say you had it in your eye for
almost the full day i can only imagine
how annoying that was that's something
you would never get used to you know
what's gross have you ever gone down a a
wormhole so to speak about um like
parasites on people that that have been
in them yes for like they live they live
under your skin yeah and then like you
cut like a little there's like a little
thing appears on your toe and you pull
it's like the length of your body um
anyway freya uh thank you for those
would you rather those were great and i
take care of hippie and hoppy i'm trying
to see what type of frog that is um
showing me like i'd be able to identify
it it's got a little yellow underbelly
it's really cool looking it looks like
maybe a bull frog
a bullfrog or a green frog we have a lot
of wood you want to finish the letter
yes okay here we go uh it's almost done
all the best christian and freyja
fairfield connecticut our neighbors p.s
thanks for the vietnamese restaurant
recco phonantrong phonantrong it's great
um we should go get some of that and
also there's mama chow on the post road
another great
asian infused restaurant yes uh mama and
her family are awesome and they make a a
killer kale cell you wouldn't think that
so hopefully you uh around town
christian and freya maybe trader joe's
maybe we'll bump into each other one day
yeah that'd be great thanks for uh
writing it and thank you to the
just sublime julie bowen blime's a good
word she would make fun of you for it i
don't care
um
and thank and julie thanks for listening
and jerry thanks for listening and
everybody stay tuned by the way for uh
voice memo
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life short is hosted by me justin long
it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long and who else megan monaco
but there's a senior producer in that
shell
audio engineer is sergio enriquez and
they're two executive producers one
marshall louie annan lopez it's for a
company called um wandering right well
great job at changing things up
very impressive well you know we got to
keep it fresh for the kids
friends
[Music]
on ballers
i didn't tell you this uh
oh wait i kind of just want to show you
a picture
out i worked in one of they're like it's
have you heard of a guy named quanto or
quanto
i'll give you a hint as to he's a rap
he's in a rapper group
they're very popular
he
uh um
uh
what's that
it sounds like a breakfast taco
breakfast
their group sounds like a breakfast taco
amiga
yeah he's one of the migos
he's amigo and i was like uh how did you
know he was a vegan they took somebody
told me
he's amigo and they're like he's in
migos they were very like vegas right
now amigas is the breakfast taco i
thought they were called amigas too
no i think they're migos the migos
they're the amigos
you